My Dad told me that if I made a
wish at 1111 it will come true.
Who was the last thing he taught
me before he got sick? Everyday.
I wish that he would get better,
but he never did.
Now I just wish that my
life wouldn't matter.
It looks like I've got you
free thousand hours. Lucky me.
Just do what you're told and I'll make
sure you're a community service doesn't
become prison.
Children's hospital has must be
the judges idea of a sick joke.
What's a matter?
You don't like Tacos?
Those are not tacos.
It was a real taco.
Santa on the way home from school,
but it got shut down.
Oh shoot.
It's 1111 make a wish.
What are you talking about?
Have you heard of 1111 wishes?
Sounds stupid. All right.
Shoot yourself.
Okay.
You just made a wish. No I
didn't. Yes you did and I saw you.
What'd you wish for
my cancer to go away?
Do you think it worked?
I heard you have to make small wishes
first here. Just making stuff up now. No,
it's the truth.
You have to get things warmed up.
You know what else I heard?
I heard you have to write your wishes
down here. I know you're lying.
We'll try it.
See what happens.
What did you do that for? Don't
worry. It's part of the process.
Yeah.
Hey Sergio.
Did you tell someone my wish
because I wish for real tacos
and it happened a piece of paper.
I'm wishing for $1 million. Uh, hello.
You have to start with small wishes first,
right?
Well
maybe you should make another way.
Sha Kale.
Chris, Chris. Chris
was for, where's Chris?
We had to move from
upstairs to critical care
and you'd just see him.
I'm sorry. It's family.
Chris is the closest
thing I've got to family.
I'm not just going to disappear on them.
I need to grant him those wishes.
Weight belts.
Now at this point
you made the last few weeks of Chris's
life. Amazing. You did a good thing,
but it's time to like
I've been waiting for you,
Chris. I'm sorry. Why you sorry.
Your wishes
not real.
There was me. I was finding your
wishes and I was making them come true.
I
know
much you want to get better,
but I don't have the ability,
have the ability to
grant you this last week,
every day at 1111 to me,
my dad told me that if I made a
wish and 1111 you don't come true.
I guess he was right.